for one of Marvel Studios biggest
upcoming movies Eternals is keeping a
pretty low profile if you're still in
the dark on the MC use newest superhero
team here's everything you need to know
about them and how their film fits into
phase four from its far-reaching
connections to existing characters to
its diverse and exciting cast Eternals
was officially announced in July 20th
2019 at San Diego comic-con and Marvel
wasted no time in confirming a few
details about the movie namely that it's
scheduled to premiere on November 6 2020
although the film is only just confirmed
at comic-con Marvel fans have been
hearing news about knee eternals film
being in the works since at least the
spring of 2018 by 2019 word begin
getting out about which actors were in
talks to star in the film and before the
film was even announced at comic-con
production was already in its early
stages in London of course November 2020
may feel like a long waits but Marvel
fans will be able to tide themselves
over with the release of Black Widow on
May 1st 2020 and the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier on Disney Plus in the
fall of that year I'll do my best
[Music]
as well as yours even longtime marvel
fans might not be too knowledgeable
about exactly who the Eternals are or
the exact details of their role in the
Marvel Universe afterall they only first
appeared in a relatively limited run of
comic books in the mid 1970's and 80's
their storyline was revived for a
miniseries by Neil Gaiman in 2006
however which brought the characters
into the modern Marvel Universe so who
are the Eternals and what is their
significance to the Marvel Universe
according to Marvel or an alien species
called the Celestials visited earth
millions of years ago and began carrying
out experiments and early humans one
offshoot of these experiments were the
Eternals beings that look like humans
yet possessed abilities like flight
mind-reading in an almost unbelievable
level of strength and endurance their
superpowers and resilience made them
essentially immortal and indestructible
but the Celestials experiments were also
responsible for the creation of the
deviance another group of humanoids who
were burdened with genetic mutations and
grotesque appearances humans mistook the
Eternals for gods and the Eternals often
clashed with the deviants to protect
humanity
however the Eternals weren't unfailingly
perfect either as will likely be
depicted in the film that can often be
misled and instigate conflicts among
themselves at this point the MCU has
introduced a countless number of
characters from the original Marvel
comics but at Vans been introduced to
any of the Eternals yet well kind of in
the comics Thanos who destroyed half of
all life in the universe and was finally
defeated by the Avengers in endgame was
actually an eternal and yeah that might
seem a little confusing especially since
the Eternals were supposed to be
protecting humanity not wiping it out
and tend to be able to physically blend
in among humans too but Thanos was a bit
of a wild card because he also possessed
a recessive deviant gene explaining his
appearance his status as an outlier
however means you can reasonably expect
that most of the characters and eternals
will be entirely new to the MCU
in fact given that the MCU has never
shied away from streamlining their
characters dense histories for the
screen it's entirely possible that
Thanos may not even come up then again
[Music]
inevitable eternals actually shares a
connection with one other film in the
MCU in guardians of the galaxy volume 2
Peter Quill's father ego tells Peter
that he is a celestial and his portrayed
as possessing godlike abilities ego is
millions of years old and is also able
to manipulate the matter of the universe
around him by the time we meet him in
guardians volume 2 he has managed to
form a whole planet around himself but
he can also inhabit a human body I don't
know where I came from
exactly first thing I remember is
flickering adrift in the cosmos utterly
and entirely if you've seen Guardians
volume 2 you'll know what happens next
and if you haven't then let's just say
that ego isn't quite as benevolent as he
first appears it's also probably safe to
say that Celestials clearly aren't an
all-powerful force for good in the
universe there's a good chance they're
going to show up once more during
Eternals - and judging by how they've
come across so far there's a good chance
they could be driving the movies primary
conflicts unfortunately for spoiler
Hungry Marvel fans pretty much everyone
involved with eternals is keeping the
movies exact details largely under wraps
as of right now the only real clues
anyone has about the plot come from a
few vague comments from studio President
Kevin Feige after Comic Con
he told comicbook.com it will be a story
that will introduce you to this
incredibly eclectic group of immortals
they're the focus of the story the
celeste shows go back a long way we know
a little bit about them the collector
told us about Celestials know where is
the severed head of a celestial ego was
involved with them but we learned much
more about their agenda and what they've
been up to if you want to form your own
predictions about what might happen in
the film this early on you'll have to
turn to the original comics there's a
good chance the plot will be inspired by
the more recent Neil Gaiman miniseries
in which the Eternals have assumed
normal human identities and forgotten
their origins sources have also told The
Hollywood Reporter that the film will
include a love story between Icarus and
another eternal Cersei but at this point
this is all just speculation as of right
now what could actually happen is
anyone's guess the cast of the Eternals
is rounded out with a listers and rising
stars alike and while big names alone
can never guarantee a movies success it
seems like Marvel have given fans a lot
to look forward to nonetheless for
example Richard Madden who rose to fame
playing the ill-fated Robb Stark in Game
of Thrones has
signed on to play Icarus Icarus is known
as the prime eternal in the comics
meaning that he is more powerful than
the other Eternals he is filled by
cosmic energy and can move at super
speed and communicate telepathically his
sheer physical strength and agility also
makes him a formidable opponent in
combats in fact there's little that
Icarus can't do and there's a good
chance that Eternals will be centered
around Icarus is one of the main
protagonists if it seems like Madden's
name has been everywhere lately you're
not imagining things
he starred in the critically acclaimed
British TV series bodyguard and also
played John Reed in Rocket Man the
musical biopic of Elton John's life get
in the studio makes music oh don't I
don't care from the looks of it being
killed off in Game of Thrones is one of
the best things that could ever have
happened to his career when word got out
that Angelina Jolie was in talks to
appear in the Eternals the prevailing
rumor was that she would be signing on
to play the eternal Cersei but at
comic-con it was confirmed that Jolie
was actually playing a different eternal
fina in the Marvel Universe the city of
Athens Greece was reportedly built for
thena not the goddess Athena as is the
case in our universe in Marvel's history
human beings confusing FINA and Athena
bred hostility between the Eternals and
the Olympic gods of Greek mythology
eventually leading to an all-out war in
game ins Eternals comics Tina works as a
researcher at Stark Enterprises and
starts remembering her past as an
eternal through a series of recurring
nightmares Jolie is definitely the
biggest name attached to this film right
now and she's ecstatic to be a part of
the MCU she told The Hollywood Reporter
I'm going to work ten times harder I
know what we all need to do we have all
read the scripts we all know what the
task ahead is and we know what you
deserve so we are all going to be
working very very hard Madden and Jolie
joining the MCU is definitely big news
but the Eternals casting getting the
most positive buzz right now is Lauren
rid laughs role as Macari you may know
read law from her previous work on The
Walking Dead or her former title as Miss
deaf America which she held from 2000
through 2002 Ridd love was born deaf and
is one of the few deaf actors in
Hollywood she has always wanted to see
more representation for her community
on-screen now she has made film history
as the first deaf superhero in the MCU
her casting represents a major change
from the original comics Macari was
actually a male character and he was
written as death but the reception to
this change has been positive so far and
fans are looking forward to seeing rid
lofts portrayal of Macari and eternal
with the power of SuperSpeed at
comic-con rid loss was asked about her
feelings on playing Macari and becoming
Marvel's first deaf superhero she
replied I do have a son and he asked me
after he read Greek mythology he was
reading through that and he's like what
does honor mean this this is what honor
means I'm so honored to be here over all
the rest of the cast of the Eternals is
pretty stacked Kumail Nanjiani will be
playing King Oh an eternal who rarely
utilizes his actual superpowers instead
he spent years studying with the samurai
in Japan and now wields a sword with the
ability to cut through any material
Bryan Tyree Henry will be appearing as
Fastow's who basically develops all the
high-tech gear and equipment that the
Eternals need salma hayek has signed on
to play a jack who often has to serve as
a diplomat between the Eternals and the
Celestials this is because a jack was
originally the only eternal with the
ability to directly communicate with
their creators Don Lee is taking on the
role of Gilgamesh an eternal who has
fought alongside the Avengers on
numerous occasions but has been largely
overlooked until now Leah McHugh the
youngest member of the main cast is
playing sprites as the name suggests
she's a mischievous trickster whose
pranks have always gotten her into
trouble new cast members will
undoubtedly be announced his production
continues director Chloe Zhao will be at
the helm of Eternals Zhu is a newcomer
to the world of Marvel in fact she's
relatively new to Hollywood in general
she directed her first feature film
songs my brothers taught me in 2015
she's best known for her 2017
contemporary western film the rider
which follows a young cowboy after an
accident nearly kills him and brings an
end to his writing career the rider was
nominated for both Best Feature and Best
Director at the 33rd Independent Spirit
Awards South history as an indie
filmmaker makes her an interesting
choice for director this film definitely
represents a new artistic direction for
Zhao but considering her numerous
accolades there's no doubt that the
movie is in good hands cousins Matthew
and Ryan Firpo teamed up to write the
script the two have one film ruined in
pre-production already but a release
date is yet to be announced and this
movie will most likely be their feature
writing debut in short it's clear
Eternals is filled with fresh talents
both behind and in front
camera check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the MCU are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]